are you anti plot against plot in the
middle so I'm definitely not against
plot I wrote sitcom for 25 years is all
about plot Edward breaks happen at
certain times you need to have certain
things happen in certain places to
motivate the advert breaks interestingly
enough now though with television not
having so many ever breaks you know with
Netflix where you its on-demand and so
you don't have your advert breaks I
think I do think plots changing slightly
the three-act structure and the
terminology around the 3x structure
that's developed over the years it's
really useful after you've written
something I find and I I just can't get
this out of my head but for me it feels
like human beings have been telling
stories for thousands of years before
we've been analyzing them so like we
told stories naturally around the
campfires you know we told stories about
the hunt Amata way to find the animals
there was some sort of structure in that
in a way yes there was a main character
trying to find an animal and there was
following throughs and so there was some
sort of a structure already to that
which is maybe a universal myth I'm not
sure but weaving time stories for a long
time longer than we've been analysing
stories so for me plot and the analysis
of plot can be a real source of people
getting stuck in their writing because
they feel that they need to have a plot
that works before they write now if you
just write without a plot you can also
end up down a dark hole of loose ends
that you know lead nowhere and just
right for the rest of your life without
having a structure but I find plot and
the analysis of plot a good place to be
once you've written something but for me
plot arises out of characters in a space
doing something and that creates the
plot the characters themselves are
almost it's like this whole separation
of character and plot is is not actually
real when you're either creating it or
watching it character the plot are
intrinsically linked we separate them in
order to analyze and maybe in the
rewrite write our stories better but I
do find that so if you just focus on
plot and drop the characters
it can result in stories that are feel a
bit empty and it can result in stories
that everyone's written before what I
find really funny about these books on
plot and some really good books are
written on plot and I point to them in
my book I don't talk about plot at all
in my book what I find really funny
about books on plot is they'll say these
seven beats need to be in a story they
don't have to be there in that order
they don't all have to be there and I'm
like what do you mean if they don't have
to be there metal and they don't all
have to be there this is kind of it's
like a weird and if you read close means
we've all got this disclaimer of like
you know they don't have to be in that
order and they don't have to necessarily
all be there I'm like well what are you
really trying to say so I'm slightly
suspicious of generating your idea
writing from plot first I think it can
be really useful in the rewrite it's
definitely really useful in the story
edit I use it all the time when I'm
trying to help writers strengthen the
strengthen their stories but actually
the best villain plot that I've ever
heard the best quote on plot and it's
not even about plot it's from that book
on filmmaking that I mentioned earlier
by Alexander Mackendrick he says
something like the only thing you need
to know what's happening now in your
story should not be as exciting or
interesting as what may or may not
happen later it's reasonable what is
happening now shouldn't be as
interesting or exciting as what may or
may not happen later so something's
happening later and it's drawing the
story forward and it's that thing that's
happening later that you need to put in
your plot somewhere so we need to know
that something's gonna happen in the you
know you need to set it up so that
something is gonna pay off and that'll
drive the story forward and they'll keep
people watching oh I like that because
it's kind of an escapist you know it's
not really part plot but it's kind of
linked to structure in some way so yeah
I I'm not anti plot but as a matter of
fact I'm Pro plot when it comes to
analysis of the story and trying to make
it stronger because I do believe you
have to take a sledgehammer to your
story once you've written it and hit it
and either breaks something's wrong with
the structure and so you need to like
make it work but I sometimes find that a
lot of the even when people use plot to
analyze movies they try and identify
like the inciting incident and they do
the same weaving the engine to buy
different places and I'm like what is
this it's not an exact science I think
writing isn't an exact science and
people who claim that it's an exact
science are actually lying in my
experience of writing is it's not an
exact science it's it's a bit different
to that and so yeah so I I kind of worry
about the usefulness of extremely plot
driven writing books they can be useful
for some people in some places and I
wrote from that for a lot of my life
what is taking a sledgehammer to your
story though like how do you
metaphorically do that so yeah I always
think of it like this when I when you
write from a character-driven sort of
perspective or from a maybe a more
organic perspective you tentatively
connect scenes together to form a sort
of like a structure and it can be a very
fragile crystalline structure it might
not be very strong and taking a
sledgehammer to it means asking yourself
those really hard questions that
structure sort of asks you to ask in a
way is like what is your character want
now and have you told us it early enough
you know and you hit it and if it
survives it survives or when is the
transition into the new world or when is
our transition into the second act is
that stronger physically enough that's
another so these are the kind of taking
a sledgehammer to your story and if it
falls apart then it's probably not
strong enough but if it's really
crystalline strong enough structure it
holds then maybe your story is good
enough that's kind of what I mean by
taking a sledgehammer it's all those
difficult questions that story execs
will ask you or you know people who read
lots of books will ask you and and I
think I think we we do have to do that
we can't be Precious about our stories
either even though they these for me
they can be really beautiful creations
that come out of a case of good
intention at some point they're gonna
that you know your audience is gonna hit
sledgehammers at it
and does it hold does it not hold you
know you have to you have to put it
through the wringer a bit that's when
you're bringing off from the key they do
that with screenwriting videos - trust
me I know they do I know it's hilarious
I wonder sometimes how useful they are
they may be useful I definitely came
from that position in the beginning when
I was when I first taught definitely I
was all like you know why are you doing
this is ridiculous it was just like this
sort of but there's an anger around that
sometimes and I wonder about that I
actually do question where that's coming
from where is this sort of anger towards
story so I was coming from a place of
insecurity because I was I didn't really
you know I hadn't written much I was
like you know and I was like - oh my god
these students what am I gonna do I'll
be strict because here I'm strict and
now listen to me I have changed now I'm
gonna look more soft and I'm a lot more
nurturing in the way that I help people
bur their stories into the world as
opposed to you know trying to kill them
as they arrive so yeah yeah I suppose I
am I'm actually suspect of a way that
the intention is coming from in the in
the shotty story people that can shot at
people you know the drill master story
guy I'm like yeah I don't know it seems
to be coming from a mislaid place it's
just a scene in for my first interview
in LA and I'm gonna get kicked out the
tongue no no no like the scene in
Forrest Gump Gump you know one needs
like rightness face and what do you
story yes resonance that's your first
job what tell us what that's about
so resonance for me is I have a quote in
that chapter my books got quotes in
every chapter so I have a lot of quotes
in this interview but I have a quote in
that chapter that begins with which is
this it is it's a complicated quote and
it might not be easily to understand
understand just saying it but it's a
quote from Gustave Flaubert Madame
Bovary and the quote is something like
language is a cracked kettle on which we
beat our Tunes for bears to dance to
while all the while we long to move the
stars to pity
so it means language is we want to move
the Stars to pity with our angry we want
to our language to be this beautiful
thing that expresses everything we
feeling and expresses our emotions but
actually language is a cracked kettle on
which we beating our Tunes for bears to
dance - then why bears a dancer but it's
like a language fails us when it comes
to certain things I really believe I
think things like religion and faith
language fails us and logic fails us at
that point and I also believe that with
creation when we create things language
fails us to really explain what's going
on at the core of creativity and that
moment of creativity which is kind of
about books about so my little KVA is
always with the word resonance the word
resonance came out of an inability to
explain what happens to me when I'm
watching a movie and I moved or when I'm
looking at a painting and I moved or
when I'm listening to a piece of music
and I moved I use the word resonance
there because for me it feels like
something in the painting is vibrating
and it vibrates something in me and I
resonate with it and that's what I mean
by resonance is I look at a painting
like for example
yeah I look at a painting for example in
the van Gogh Museum in Amsterdam there's
this one particular painting that I saw
we'd filled with crows which is a
beautiful painting and it's just really
moved when I was in the museum looking
at this painting it really moved me and
resonated with me in a really deep way I
hope it wasn't cuz I was in Amsterdam
and things can move you there which
shouldn't but I'm sure it wasn't that
but other things move me you know
paintings and moments and movies move me
particularly music will move me
characters maybe in a certain way will
move me and that movement and that
resonance is what I'm trying to create
in the scripts that my writers are
writing is how do we take that resonance
how do we make our audience in reading a
script never mind watching it but how do
you make that in them resonate with
what's on the page that for me is the
real trick of writing
and I do believe you're doing we do that
by doing what Hemingway says we do which
is it's very easy you just said the
typewriter and bleed you know we take
our memory well we put it on the stage
you put our pint of blood on the stage
and that's what the way we create
resonance because if it moved us in our
memories if it stayed in our memories
for some way so for some reason it might
have had a resonance it might have this
charge that we then put on the page and
then people reading it resonate with it
so that's kind of what I mean by
resonance of course it can get really
complicated because you do need
structure sometimes to get to that point
where people are moved you know you need
to have certain things in place so that
you know you we care about the character
so that when they do something we moved
by it but I still believe that they're
certain sort of events in our lives even
objects and senses and sounds and
touches and tastes which we free take
from our memory where they have they
carry this weight of resonance you put
them on the page and there it is and
it's a it's a it's a difficult thing to
to do consciously but you can and it's
also difficult to kind of talk about
because it's so abstract but you
recognize it immediately when you see it
I mean I know you know what I'm talking
about but it's difficult to kind of do
it except by accessing your memories and
being very vulnerable it's also about
being vulnerable I think and putting
yourself out there you some of some of
your vulnerability and then people will
resonate with it I think because if it's
too much of just your own vulnerability
it becomes a manifesto without that
structure exactly this is where you know
what I always say is like I don't want
this book I don't want to hear about
your life your boring life because I
actually don't I want to hear about
something else maybe you know I don't
want to just read about your life I want
to read about
I want aspects of your life to be
present in the story you telling and
that's different the story you're
telling is a story it's you have
structure it should have you know and it
but but you put your memories in the
aspects of it and then it really starts
to come alive and just to kind of go
back to the story structure thing maybe
and back to that van Gogh painting cuz I
love that van Gogh painting it was using
an example because I know I don't know
what van Gogh was doing when he painted
but I know that he didn't have a test
and he didn't read a book on
screenwriting theory and he didn't put
his painting up and say to everyone
right guys look at this painting are
there enough crows in the painting
refuels crows or the other do you want
more yellow and then hand out flying
forms and in the audience or fold it in
and then like handed it back to him and
he changed it so that didn't happen so
he was doing something else which I
think he sees he was resonating and he
was just moving with emotion he put that
on the canvas now of course he didn't
have to pay millions of dollars for that
canvas which is why you need maybe
audience test subjects to give you you
know see if your movies working or not
but if you write from a position of okay
I got a piece and audience I'm gonna
make money out of this and let me read a
book on structure I don't know if you
hit the resonance not always
you